[Applause]
okay here's how it works
this is a true story according to
network research one group of viewers
that is extremely valuable to our
advertisers is geologists who were
really into the music of smash specific
specific yeah I told you this was
specific geologists that are really into
Smash Mouth that's what the data says
there's a lot of money we're just
leaving on the table if we don't get
them to watch the show let's get it yeah
let's get them yeah let's get him
so geologists who are really into the
music of Smash Mouth here's some
entertainment just for you
it's igneous rocks that are sometimes
confused for sedimentary rocks
[Music]
this is just called nothing so now
nothing
[Music]
well let's find out what do you think
about that geologist
[Laughter]
[Applause]
what did the bird meet if you think you
know please contact us